prepare you for the day that approaches
is the day of the great revolution are
you ready to roll you live to see the
accidental dominance of the white race
overthrown cool you're gonna fish me the
next 911 what about this guy Moses
Shabazz classic lone wolf there's four
of them actually back a lone wolf had to
happen my mission is to change the lives
of poor people without the gun well
what's offer this Moses Shabazz some
funds he could set up a meeting with our
rich ISIL Sheikh perhaps your army needs
weapons no we don't believe in God if
necessary we'll call along the dinosaurs
there at the sound of a trumpet they
will come to our aid I think he's yeah
let's get your friend new place me could
you pay someone to inform upon
themselves you want to inform on
yourself would you be interested he's
got a threat signature of a hot dog John
has no off switch next thing you know
the Statue of Liberty is wearing a burka
and we've the headed Bruce Springsteen
just get him back out there to blow up a
skyscraper or I'll drop the case okay so
we have to get him a fake you I'll take
a better idea if you got one all about
not selling news to Nazis
uranium to put hair on your chest and
make it fall off I am just a guy talking
to another guy trying to send a third
guy to jail I'm calling in a full armed
response which one's more likely to have
a gun
[Music]
you think this gonna work out
you